our parents form a big part of our
personality during the time when we
completely depend on their care
this happens because as young children
we perceive them as almighty endlessly
wise and flawless
we also believe that whatever they do
literally whatever they do
they do out of unconditional love
and because we think they are infallible
and full of love we consequently think
that we are at fault whenever a conflict
arises
in order to reduce any kind of conflict
we develop patterns of behavior feelings
and thinking designed to please our
parents and minimize any friction
unfortunately these patterns can lead to
the development of a personality that is
misaligned with its true spiritual self
and so we grow into adults that behave
in ways that make us sad
the hoffman process was designed to help
us recognize negative behavioral
patterns break them and to become the
person we really are
to condense a lifetime of analysis into
seven days the process is highly
structured very intense and applies a
multitude of techniques
afterwards participants often understand
why they are the way they are and learn
to let go of the negative sides of their
personality
to understand how the process works let
us look at three types of people who on
the outside look just fine but on the
inside deeply struggle
eva is 27 a university graduate and she
has just started her first job
she's unable to trust men and is at a
loss when it comes to forming healthy
relationships
jay is 51 an overachiever and a
respected ceo
however his marriage is broken and his
two adult children hardly ever call
he asks himself if that's really all
that life has to offer
tom is 45 married with one child but
he's got no friends he lives with his
family far outside town and signs up for
the process when he realizes that his
daughter also has problems making
friends
through the process eva will realize
that when her dad left when she was four
and her mother then struggled as a
single mom and a lonely woman it had a
big impact on her
over the years her own relationship with
her father became broken and she learned
that men couldn't be trusted
jay will learn that his life was going
great up until his little brother was
born a funny extroverted and bright boy
afterwards jay was hardly ever noticed
jay soon realizes that his parents would
only pay attention to him if he excelled
in school or sports causing him to grow
into an adult who tries to be the best
in everything in order to get the love
he seeks
tom will realize that he was an accident
born to a young couple who had just
begun dating
as a young boy he was often neglected
because their life was difficult his
parents who were overwhelmed by the
situation would often snap at him over
the smallest thing
little tom began to think that he was
the cause of all misery he should never
have been born
the process begins with a phone call
from a designated therapist
this is followed by a 50-page
questionnaire that helps their client to
reflect on their lives
going through the questions the
participants identify particular
patterns in behavior and link them to
their parents
once returned the therapist uses the
questionnaire to understand the
underlying issues
on day one all three arrive at the
retreat a place isolated from the
outside world they hand over their
phones and any books to ensure there are
no distractions
tom then meets his therapist for an
in-depth conversation
afterwards he gets to know the other 17
participants and learns that everyone
carries within them an inner child that
manages their expectations thoughts and
feelings
on day two jay and the others learn more
about their parents and how their
behavioral patterns have formed out of
love for their father and mother
jay who only got real attention when he
impressed his parents could never be
good enough to get all the love he
needed such conditional love is negative
because subconsciously jay takes on the
blame for this disjunction and develops
a core shame belief
he begins to think something is
inherently wrong with himself
and so even after 50 years of trying so
hard to be the best his inner child is
still looking for the unconditional love
he got so little of
on day three eva realizes how the
patterns she established as a young girl
subconsciously project into her adult
relationships
anyone who reminds eva of her father
can't be trusted
through a group game later that day she
experiences that there are men she can
rely on
eva then accuses her parents of making
her the victim of their broken
relationship this is important because
this way she can retrace her negative
pattern back to her parents
afterwards she learns to understand
their story because they too were once
children with parents who had their own
issues
this is important because then she can
understand their situation and realizes
that the way she was brought up was all
her parents were able to provide
now she can make peace with her past and
her mistrust of men begins to wither
on day four participants say goodbye to
their parents and their childhood and
ask themselves where am i from
what injuries do i bring along from my
mother and father
how have these injuries impacted my life
what strategies have i developed to
compensate for these injuries so far
jay who didn't want to be reminded of
the painful thought that he's not worthy
of his parents unconditional love
compensated by only contacting them when
he had outstanding news such as another
promotion knowing that they would then
surely listen and act predictably he
reduces the risk of feeling hurt
after this realization jay creates a
development plan to follow his vision
for life after the process
day five is about our vindictiveness
tom who didn't want to be reminded that
he is the root of all problems
compensated for the pain he experienced
by hiding himself
at a young age children keep their honor
by thinking of how to one day pay their
parents back for the misery they caused
them
as we mature such vindictive thoughts
move into the subconscious and by the
time he is a teenager tom begins to pay
back
first by breaking the law then by
breaking all contacts with his friends
and family
on this day tom stops feeling vindictive
and makes peace with his parents
his inner child regains his honor and
grows in strength
grown-up tom can now leave his hiding
place and finally enjoy meeting other
people
on day six the participants get to know
the saboteur the inner voice that warns
us of any change in order to keep us in
the safe old world we know so well
eva hears the voice whenever she opens
up to the opposite sex it whispers
remember you can't trust men
tom hears it when he enters a group of
people
you are not welcome here
whenever jay tries to relax and be
himself the saboteur says don't just do
nothing you are better than this
after getting to know this evil agent
they learn how to deal with this enemy
of our progress
then the group recaps the entire process
and celebrates their newfound selves
on day seven they learn practical tools
on how to cope with the change they will
face when they go back into their lives
finally they go home to their parents to
complete what they have started end
their old lives and begin afresh
to learn more about the hoffman process
or to read the research on it by the
harvard center for public leadership
check out the descriptions below prior
to creating this channel our founder
went through the hoffman process and it
had a profound effect on his life
[Music]
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and
non-profit organizations can also use
them for training online courses or
designing new curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute just visit patreon.com
sprouts even one dollar can make a
difference